you know what's exciting to raise
another subject but one utterly related
to the god issue and everything else
it's exciting to make a family it's not
exciting to stay single it was single is
not as exciting as marriage i've been
both
and uh uh i know that a lot of single
people think you can't think of anything
more boring than being married
they they they they don't understand
that
making a family raising kids having a
partner through life that's damn damn
exciting compared to gee where will i
have dinner tonight i'm single i can
decide i don't have to bounce that off
somebody else but you know what i think
happens for a lot of people is
for one they don't understand the value
they don't understand their roots or the
history or the cultural significance and
we've become uh
gluttonous in a sense
good times make weak men as it were uh
what i was going to say is that if
there's one thing that is a wake-up call
to anyone who is single that you need to
have a family it's going to the hospital
being a single adult male and having an
issue with go to the hospital and you're
lying in that bed all by yourself
and you're like oh this is this is very
bad like
you're in trouble that's a tough one
because if you haven't been married you
don't know how great it is i think right
because this society for the first time
in its history has not told every young
person get married they tell them get a
career
and then so all these career women call
my show that's that's the great
advantage of having a talk show i talk
to
i talk with people not just two people i
talk with them in half for 40 years and
uh i should make a collection of of the
calls from women 50
who have phds and who and and who make
uh easily well into six figures but they
have no husband and they have no
children and uh they they they believe
they were sold a terrible bill of goods
and they were so let's talk about this
we you know we've had um various dating
experts and personalities talk about
this issue
i'm curious on what the experience is
what do you commonly hear from women who
have careers over families
look the uh i i have to be
intellectually honest tell you these are
the ones calling my show they may well
call a left-wing show and say oh i am so
thrilled i never had a husband and
children uh because i can't tell you how
much i enjoy being the ceo of of of this
uh computer software company that that
may well be i can't imagine such a
person by the way i can't imagine it
even in a man and men are more driven in
generally speaking in in the in the
macro arena just the way male nature is
for better or for worse uh but uh uh the
uh the according to
even the new york times the it is the
highest rate of depression among young
women in american history we have never
had what we have had now it is
completely a function of of of the
feminist lie
that a woman without a man is like a
fish without a bicycle oh you don't need
men you need a career that will really
make your life and it was a function of
the lockdowns what i called in april
2020 people can see it on the internet i
was universally mocked for it the
greatest mistake in history
on a worldwide uh basis the lockdowns
which they turned out to be uh yet uh
yet people bought it
for for uh reasons because once they
hear
experts say experts say to the secular
is what thus saith the lord is to the
religious do you think that maybe uh
maybe birth control is playing a role in
in in this
so um you know it's hormonal mass
medication of young women and obviously
the left's attitude is it's good it's
important that way women can can date
and and be promiscuous and have to worry
about having a baby and they can
maintain their career but i'm also
wondering if if it uh perhaps alters the
the perception one thing we've that i've
read is that uh women often get advised
to get off birth control before marrying
their partner their significant other
because
it alters their perception and many
women will find after getting off birth
control their their man smells bad and
they say that if that's true don't marry
them because something's not right but
being on birth control clouds that that
perception
if that's the case i'm wondering if this
is also clouding other issues and
perhaps
if a woman is on birth control maybe
it's an issue of you know when she comes
off for control birth control and she's
older and that hormone is removed from
the body maybe her perception changes or
something to that effect i never heard
that uh
you have you heard that lydia sorry
about the smell thing i have heard that
about the smell thing and i've heard
that if you smell your partner and they
don't it's very subconscious and
sometimes you don't even notice it until
after you're not on birth control
anymore now i don't exactly have
anything that i i personally can say
about this because i lost my sense of
smell to covet in november it's been
gone since november it's been gone for a
really long wow and i'm getting to the
point where i'm worried that when i have
my first child i won't be able to smell
them which is horrifying but when you
bring up the sense of smell with women
it's like they don't even realize it's
something that they're missing so it's
very subconscious and i think it's
something that should definitely it has
a lot to do with pheromones and it has a
lot to do to see if they're compatible
with each other biologically um and this
is why you know a lot of people also put
on a lot of heavy metals and deodorants
right in their armpits right into one of
their the major flows of blood in their
entire body that also has a lot of
negative health consequences there's
been horror stories after horror stories
when it comes to birth control in women
and and business insider had a very
interesting article in 2015 that was
titled women now control more than half
of us personal wealth which will only
increase in years to come and i think
i don't know if you could pinpoint it to
one particular thing but we are seeing
the destruction of the family unit we
are seeing a depopulation plan that has
been rolled out that is implemented and
we're seeing the larger consequences of
this where elon musk just tweeted even a
couple hours ago about u.s birth rates
being below minimal sustainable levels
for over 50 years now the fertility
rates have been dropping testosterone
rates have been dropping right right
a lot of children
religious catholics religious jews
religious protestants and religious
mormons well i'll i'll tell you i know
everybody who listens to this shows
they've heard me say it there was a
study in the early 2000s that found
conservatives were having about 2.01
kids per family and liberals were having
like 1.73
the logic is simple 20 years later we
see in pew research gen z is slightly
more conservative than millennial but
they're very very similar well it makes
sense it's not that gen z were
red-pilled it's that conservatives had
more kids so if you get 100
conservatives 100 liberals and the
liberals only have 70 kids out of 100
100 parents and the conservatives have
100 kids you take that 100 conservative
kids and 70 liberal kids put them
together and pull the 170 and you're
like wow it's mostly conservative i
wonder why
simply put there was a i read a story
that said the future is muslim
because muslims have even more kids than
christian conservatives do and they said
it's simple math
that if liberals are are going to be
aborting their children and not and just
not trying to have kids in the first
place more likely for the women to have
careers conservatives are more likely to
have kids but devout religious
fundamentalist muslim are having
substantially more kids then the future
will skew in the direction of that faith
and a lot of the the people who don't
have a religion don't believe in in a
higher power usually are more
susceptible to propaganda on the
television and there's been a lot of
subliminal propaganda saying don't have
children this is especially true in
europe where there's major
advertisements saying you could be more
free you could enjoy life more if you
don't have your children and don't have
your children because it's bad for the
environment moral that's it you're
morally obligated exactly
for the
carbon emissions problem i think it's
funny that that there's that meme that
says you are the carbon they are trying
to reduce yeah that's a misnomer about
carbon when they literally write
articles saying that it's like there's
this belief that we have too much and
that that's that but we're going to
start pulling carbon out of the air
there's technology where you can deposit
carbon dioxide onto palladium and create
graphene out of it which is just a
monoatomic layer of carbon and then we
can reuse the graphene as a building
material so we'll start harvesting the
carbon dioxide and competing with trees
and then we're going to need more carbon
dioxide they they will uh i am convinced
that the greens
if we had perfect technology to remove
carbon dioxide they would still push
for uh for uh
sun
solar panels and uh
and uh
windmills
but not nuclear power that's that's the
proof right nuclear power is the proof
there is a romantic fixation on
bringing us back to the 17th century or
18th century
nuclear power is powers 60 of france's
electricity it is safe
uh it is clean if if indeed carbon is
dirty it is clean and yet they are
opposed to nuclear power so if that i've
read about that and you would think that
they would be thrilled to know that but
they are no more thrilled about removing
carbon dioxide than they are about
nuclear power they want us to use solar
panels
and wind power germany got rid of all of
their their nuclear power plants
because well i i have a theory uh which
is not meant to be bigoted uh uh and
there are certainly exceptions but my
theory is germany is always wrong no
when angela merkel did that
she just fed my belief germany is always
wrong
well they were they were really hoping
to be dependent upon russian gas and oil
so isn't that beautiful if i could ask
you because you said you traveled in a
lot of eastern european countries uh if
you don't mind me transitioning here
what do you think of what's happening in
ukraine right now what's your
perspective from everything since
there's a mainstream media establishment
push from one perspective but it's a
very complicated situation
so i don't think it's as complicated as
a lot of my my
fellow uh conservatives think it is
uh russia did something evil in invading
ukraine
uh you can you can think things through
to the end was is the ukrainian
government corrupt okay if we don't
defend
the the uh independence of a country
because the government is corrupt we
will never defend any country
uh government is corrupt almost by
definition because power corrupts an
absolute power corrupts absolutely as
was said by lord acton in the 19th
century tends to corrupt absolutely
oh is that we said tens i thought i
thought corrupt all right either way i i
take a look by i am curious i want to i
want to quote it correctly either way
it's accurate uh so uh
look
uh
this this is this what we should do is a
separate question
from the moral one remember i think in
moral terms the invasion of ukraine
the obliteration of its independence or
the attempt to do so is evil if that's
not evil then then then why was why why
was germany's invasion of poland evil
so uh lord acton said power tends to
corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely
so i got the second part right and the
first part wrong because i dropped tens
from the first part and i think i i was
assuming the tens is on the last part
right so yeah we both got one part wrong
so so what do you think about the the 40
billion and now today the okay so one
billion that's going to ukraine uh as of
right so that's a that's a very fair
question uh
the the original sin about the 40
billion is that we printed a trillions
of dollars of dollars uh by because of
the democrats
and and that is what has created the uh
not the only thing that has created the
terrible inflation
and the other is that we are now giving
not from our surplus weapon weaponry but
from our uh the heart of our weaponry
because the democrats have over the
course of decades said we don't need so
many weapons as we have
but if america is not the strongest
country on earth
cruelty will dominate the earth that's
just the fact of life and conservatives
should be the first to say that
but what does that does what does that
mean i mean
we're looking at a multipolar world with
china
now coming to compete and my belief is
that china is looking and saying whoa
if uh if sweden and uh and finland want
now to join nato
uh maybe it's a maybe the backlash
against putin
may have us think rethink our desire to
invade taiwan i don't think that china
is more likely to invade taiwan
given the reaction of the western world
to russia i think they're less likely to
do so i thought the same thing
really yeah yeah most people uh think
differently i think they think uh this
is emboldening china i don't think it's
emboldening china you see the way russia
got annihilated financially when it
happened yes that's right exactly
well if you look at the markets now it's
far more complicated but earlier we
talked about how do we prevent the loss
of life how can we do that especially in
ukraine when i i think it's very
essential and very clear that the united
states is just giving them enough
weapons to prolong this war they gave
them specific hardware that was missing
uh equipment on it that would have been
a game changer for the ukrainians but
but they're giving equipment just enough
to prolong the conflict but not have a
decisive victory
emmanuel macron the president of france
came to this larger kind of geopolitical
conundrum and he said that there has to
be some kind of a peace deal there has
to be some kind of negotiation um and
he's he's even suggesting some kind of
way to de-escalate this entire situation
i would love to see is is your
perspective do you only escalate or is
your perspective you should obliterate
no i would love to de-escalate
uh but uh
look
if you really want a an original sin or
at least a beginning sin
uh uh in the direction of what you're
saying it is it is this president
which i say with difficulty i admit this
president saying uh that uh putin has to
go
you have put putin in the place of i
have no choice but to win
but
but for the new york times and and the
entire
elite of this country
there is no
sin biden can commit
because any democrat is better than any
republican and by the way i believe
virtually any republican is better than
any democrat so i just want to make that
clear i think the democrats are ruining
america they think republicans are
ruining america that's why we we may
have a civil war that is correct that
was your original point of the of the of
our dialogue here but but his saying
putin has to go that he's a war criminal
then putin is going to say i'm crazy for
for
for for doing anything but going whole
hog into into ukraine they they've given
the man no way out not they biden and
the democrats
yeah i think the whole situation is
extremely dangerous i i i it is
extremely dangerous striving towards you
know negotiations de-escalation yeah but
he does he doesn't want to negotiate i
agree with you why would you so why
would you say i agree since i agree with
you
what is the modus operandi that we would
get him to negotiate
say we'll give you eastern ukraine
this is that's what biden actually
proposed the president of the united
states actually proposed doing that uh
is that a solution no i don't claim to
know any any answers here but i think uh
aggravating the situation is definitely
not not the right approach here i think
aggravating and defending are identical
uh yeah you always aggravate a situation
when you arm the victim well if we're
going to be doing something here we we
should do it decisively not to prolong a
proxy conflict well i don't know well um
and you know there's there's been
specific military munitions especially
when it comes to the howitzers that are
missing key gps components that would
change the game but the united states is
not giving them that so so that to me i
think this is again a very complex issue
i don't claim to know the answers here i
don't claim to know the solutions as a
polish person we always have a lot of
distrust against the soviets and the
russians for good and obviously so
because of the history and the bloodshed
and the life loss that was committed
there you know and this is a conundrum
that that is is is is very well when i
went to poland uh during the cold war
because that again that was my field so
i speak russian and i spoke i go to you
know poland czech slovakia bulgaria east
germany romania so i would go there and
because i spoke russian
uh i got along because they had to learn
russian right they had no choice so i
would ask let's say a poll so i would go
yamare kanyez i'm an american cavarito
porrowski do you speak russian and every
single one gave the same answer
yes but i don't want to
it sounds like there might be people
that want a limited war right now like
another vietnam in ukraine even
kissinger came out and was like that's a
bad idea by the way he's like the
architect of limited war uh because it's
better than a total war but he's like
this is not the time or the place to do
a limited war
i don't know why maybe because
corporations are are the arms
manufacturers right now and they don't
care about any government well i i not
to deviate i suppose but dennis why do
you think ukraine's fallen out of the
news cycle
people get bored when there there is
nothing new to report and and they are
understandably more preoccupied with
their own lives whether whether whether
right or wrong
and they they are watching america
crumble uh financially economically
morally
and uh that that's the reason why what
is there to report i mean look
v vietnam i mean i'm old enough to
remember the vietnam war and
there was a point where people tuned out
of the vietnam war reports they they
were they were still made and of course
that was much more directly involved
because americans were dying americans
are not dying in ukraine which is
another factor americans are not dying
in ukraine so it's it's understandable
uh
and
and that's that thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you